Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have,
case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when his soul is taken away, Allah says
he's going to say what? Send me back to
do Hajj, Omrah, salah, fasting. What? No
sodak. Brothers and sisters, is getting
thousands of shahadas monthly, yearly.
Hundreds of thousands of people are
coming to Islam. They are printing
Quran, distributing material, training
duat. Brothers and sisters, do you want
a part of that that goes on forever?
This is how Islam has spread around the
world. Brothers and sisters, carry on
this legacy of the prophetam inshallah
by donating whatever amount inshallah
and aya right now inshallah. Enjoy the
video
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Lo and behold, Sneo just well he didn't
expose he's reacted to Tristan Tate.
Tristan Tate, if you guys remember
Andrew Tate, we've done a video about
him. I think my last video about him.
Alhamdulillah. It's clear where he's at,
what he's doing. Um working saying that
he's got a tech team in um in Israel. I
told everywhere the whole world. Nope.
I'm going to go Israel. Yes. Now,
Tristan gave us a a more more than we
could even even bargain for. Here's a
video of Sneo reacting to reacting to
two things that Tristan says that makes
everything fall. The puzzle just makes
perfect sense. Why Andrew's shift? They
can't get him to say sorry. They can't
get him to say sorry. And Patrick Pet
David humiliating him and asking him
questions. Why did you do this? Why did
you say that? Let's watch for ourselves
shot. Here's the first clip.
>> That's a very different. I just told you
I'm dating an Israeli girl right now.
She's Israeli.
[screaming]
>> My
I got tech teams in Israel. I got a mass
girlfriend.
Oh my god, bro. Oh my god. This is worse
than parody. I can't even like clip farm
or do a reaction. It's just it's it's
sillier than anything I could have said.
There's an IDF soldier right here. I've
got an Israeli girlfriend. Two-state
solution. So, perfect. So, he has so he
has an Israeli girlfriend for some odd
reason. Why is it that everyone has an
Israeli girlfriend?
[clears throat and cough]
It's bizarre. Epstein, we know he was
collected anyways. You know, his
girlfriend. Why is it that these top
figures all have Israeli girlfriends or
Israeli wives and even gave one to this
ugly bastard opposite prophet? Yeah.
Yes. The most vile ugly ugliest creature
I've heard. Like he has Latin in his
face. We can see he's got Latin in his
face. We're not they mean Allah's
creation. Yeah. They even gave him one.
I mean she she had to do a massive
sacrifice. That Israeli woman who they
said assigned to a ruan she was like h
ah not a rwan. Please give me anyone.
She really is taking one for her
country. I'm not going to lie. Being Can
you imagine being married to this dirt
bag? He was cheating on his wife. Yeah.
And this woman was Assan. She was like,
"No, no, not this guy. Please, anyone
but this fat, ugly dirt bag." Yes. Nope.
She gave it to them. But anyway, so
Trista's got an Israeli girlfriend.
Okay. Now, let's see what next.
>> My tech team is actually, you know,
mainly Israeli dudes. You know, these
are guys I rely on who can pull the plug
on my entire company,
>> you Oh.
Oh. Well, why don't you just lead with
that? What are you saying me for?
It's starting to make sense.
>> He relies on mainly Israeli. Look, it
says it was his mouth and they can pull
the plug. Just imagine, guys, they can
pull the plug. The guy has just admitted
what Andrew Tate could have not. He just
come and said, "You know what? Cuz what?
They're both partners." Yes. Okay.
They're brothers. Okay. And apparently
he said, "F you" to uh Sneo Tristan.
With all due respect, if I could say the
f word. Yeah. F you, my friend. Not not
Sneo. If anything, Sneo shows what he's
really about. He's been true to the
cause from day one. Bro, you're a
sellout. Okay. If anything, f you, bro.
If you said F you to Sneo, I'm saying to
you, bro, in a halal way. Well, we can't
say in a halal way, you know, but in a
hal. Yes. Okay. F you, man. Okay. You
are a sellout. You're not even a true
Christian. Candace is a true Christian.
People have been massacred and you don't
give a damn about that, my friend. You
don't give a crap. Okay. And here you're
saying they are mainly Israeli dudes.
Yes. Behind your tech companies and they
can pull the plug on you like that.
You're sold out, bro. You are sold out.
Look how they are controlling these
people and Allah's exposing them. They
are thinking the things are in the means
doing Cabala and this and that and
Epstein islands and funding a pedophile
island and these people are coming and
molesting and raping innocent children
and girls. And look at that. He's
admitting that he is literally look
they've caught him. They've caught him.
You know where I don't need to mention
okay they have got him on the jugly vein
and he's saying that they can put the
plug on him and that's the reason why
you saw that dynamic swift swift shift
of autate and Tristan and big shout out
to sneaker for exposing them. That's all
I'm going to say in brother and sisters
and Allah expose them and Allah tells us
that the people of the book are not the
same. Yes. Candace Owen Owens and T
Carson you can see look they're true to
their cause yes they're not connected to
money wealth and this that etc and
things to hide they it looks like they
have been compromised and it makes it
very clear all I want to do is guys
bring that to attention may Allah
subhanaa tala expose them we don't need
to bring millions if not thousands of
people to come to Islam and those people
who are affirming their religion like um
Sneo like Sonaz look Andrew Tate was the
reason yes he came to Islam maybe for
the wrong reasons, but they're all
staying for the right reasons. Allah
works in miraculous ways. So, big up the
Sony files and Sneakoff for calling out
this dirt bag.